permítanme interactuar con ustedes un
minuto voy a pedirles que levanten su
mano aquellas y aquellos que viven de
modo permanente en temuco
gracias ahora de ustedes mismos levanten
en su mano por favor aquellos y aquellas
que no nacieron en temuco
vaya no soy la única inmigrante en esta
sala bienvenidos
nací en perú
nieta de inmigrantes italianos crecí en
un ambiente lleno de colores y manteles
a cuadros las pastas y la salsa de
tomate en el almuerzo tradicional en
casa de mi nona pepín a mi abuela
paterna pero ella siempre lo combinaba
con un típico postre peruano
en casa de mis abuelos maternos la
comida era mucho más variada
generalmente a cargo de la mami josefina
pero cuando él no entraba en la cocina
él nos podía sorprender con una
exquisita fusión de comida chino peruana
esta lección de pluriculturalidad
temprana en lo cotidiano me enseñó que
por muy diversos que sean esos sabores y
colores se integraban perfectamente que
todo encajaba nada sobraba pero también
me hicieron creer que en todas partes
ser igual
que en toda casa por lo menos había un
mantel a cuadros
cuando uno llega a un país extranjero
sobre todo con el que se comparte el
idioma damos por hecho que las palabras
que decimos o la intencionalidad de
ellas van a ser bien recibidas van a ser
comprendidas pero no siempre es así
la primera vez que llegué a chile
fue un 28 de diciembre día de los santos
inocentes
embarazadísima de mi segunda hija la
primera había quedado temporalmente con
mi mamá en perú
casada con chile no tuve pues que
conocer a la familia política valor y
vaya que lo necesite desde un inicio yo
me sentí como extremadamente observada
note que sus reuniones familiares no se
parecían a las mías aquellas a las que
yo estaba acostumbrada
no siempre se sentaban todos juntos a la
mesa al mismo tiempo si era sao los que
estaban alrededor de la parrilla comían
ahí otros se sentaban otros en la cocina
algunas hermanas haciendo empanadas
tomando mate
y eso
me hizo de pronto sentir como que yo no
encajaba
queda diferente
era extranjera
pero también lo que más pena me dio fue
darme cuenta que ellos no tenían un
mantel a cuadros
de acuerdo con una de estas reuniones
familiares una cuñada inocentemente me
pregunto anita tú sabes lo que es el
pisco
en qué momento se olvidó que yo era
peruana pregúntale una persona que sabe
qué es el pico e ingenuidad o sea no
respondí nada y ahora tampoco haré
ningún comentario al respecto como esto
fueron otras anécdotas ni se imaginan
ustedes el tiempo que me la pasé
rechazando empanadas de pino no tenía la
mínima idea a que sabía el pino lo único
que se me venía en la cabeza eran estos
productos para desinfectar esto no vino
yo quería un empanada de carne a cómo
prepararan el pino que aquí es abra y ni
les cuento lo que pensé es la primera
vez que vi cuando ofrecían calzones
rotos calentitos
y cuando nació camila al día siguiente
en la visita habitual del médico me
pregunta y usted mamita cuando mejoró
y uno mejore dé a luz por eso para mí
está cuando mejoró
estos son simples ejemplos de lo que
puede ser para ustedes como para
nosotros el impacto choque cultural
hablamos el mismo idioma pero a veces no
queremos decir exactamente lo mismo pero
no todo fue divertido
cuando cambie la cumplió tres meses mi
esposo tuvo que regresar al país de
donde habíamos venido porque los
recursos estaban agotando y en este poco
tiempo no habíamos encontrado que hacer
por solamente habíamos gastado
costo
costo sola con una niña de tres meses en
un país al que no conocíamos costó
aprender a encender la estufa leña
costó salir debajo de la lluvia hace un
vehículo costó sobrevivir
de pronto yo me encerré como un caracol
en su caparazón
no abría la puerta no respondía el
teléfono durante días no comía ni me
bañaba para lo único que yo me levantaba
de la cama era para cumplir mi rol de
madre que gracias a dios jamás deje de
hacerlo
cuando camila cumplió seis meses brunel
a mi hija mayor llegó acompañada de mi
mamá
si bien es cierto esto estabilizó mi
vida emocional en parte no fue
suficiente
cuando camila cumple un año lo
celebramos pero nos fuimos yo no pude
más no pude y gracias a dios tuve la
posibilidad de poder irme
pocos años después la reconstituida
renovada reinventada con la familia
decidimos regresar y ustedes no se
pueden imaginar
cuando regresamos a chile lo primero que
me di cuenta era lo intenso del azul del
cielo temuquense conocí los hermosos
paisajes del sur chileno
y comprendí que así como llueve el sol
aquí también sale para todos
gracias a la invitación de un amigo
peruano en brasil empecé a ser
corresponsal de la página peruanos en el
exterior lo que me permitió conocer la
historia de peruanos alrededor del mundo
a lo largo de chile y aquí en la región
peruanos emprendedores valerosos
luchadores
con los cuales tengo alguna amistad
hasta ahora
y como una cosa lleva a la otra me
invitaron a formar parte de la primera
asociación de peruanos en la araucanía
integre también la primera mesa
de migrantes de la intendencia forme
también parte de la primera mesa de
mujeres migrantes en el servicio
nacional de la mujer y aquí hay género
la consecuencia de ello con un grupo de
hermosas bellas mujeres sobrevivientes
algunas de ellas formamos la red de
mujeres migrantes que hoy tengo el honor
de presidir
gracias a esta experiencia me tocó
escuchar historias de mujeres muy
parecidas a las mías
mujeres que sufrían en silencio no todas
gracias adiós mujeres que no hablaban
con ese silencio que te estanca ese
silencio que no permite que avances
ellas hablan con los ojos
y esa mirada conocía yo
así que nos abocamos a la tarea de ser
una red de acogida de acompañamiento de
contención de abrazos
de llamadas telefónicas de medianoche
de mujeres a muchas de ellas jamás le
vimos al rostro pero a las que sí
escuchamos
y siempre le dijimos una frase tranquila
tú ya no estás sola
ustedes no se imaginan lo sanadora y
salvadora que puede ser esa frase esa
frase que yo no recibí
y no me gustaría que se deje de dar
de aquí en adelante
en medio
de esta hermosa tarea autoimpuesta
el movimiento migratorio en chile se
torna más notorio
tengo un claro can y en general empiezan
a considerarla como destino final en
gran parte de ella
son una invasión lo vienen a quitar
nuestro empleo son delincuentes son sólo
de la innumerable lista de mitos que se
han apoderado día a día de las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación
y mitos que han sembrado en ustedes la
desconfianza y el temor que es
entendible
pero al mismo tiempo
salen expertos o casi expertos con datos
con cifras con cuadros reales
que demuestran que son falsos pero no
bastan el temor y la desconfianza ya
están sembrados
entonces tomemos la decisión de seguir
participando en la charla de
sensibilización a las que somos
invitadas y organizar otras tantas hasta
el día de hoy
en las que generamos un espacio
donde podamos contarte en nuestra
historia pero también escuchar la tuya
porque todos tenemos una historia que
contar y aunque ustedes no lo crean las
historias son muy similares son tan
similares que a veces la única
diferencia es la nacionalidad del
narrador
créanme que todos necesitamos ser
escuchados
si ustedes no se hacen parte de este
proceso
con la oportunidad que tenemos hoy y
aquí no será posible que construyamos la
sociedad justa y equitativa que nos
merecemos
no seremos parte del trazado de este
mapa nuevo de chile que no se detendrá
desperdiciaremos la oportunidad de tener
nuestro propio mantel a cuadros que con
piezas distintas se integra
perfectamente armoniosamente
atrévete
dejemos de levantar muros que nos
dividan levantemos banderas de
integración de desarrollo
si tu donde íntegras qué harás al margen
te invito a que nos miremos para que nos
miremos adentro y te aseguro que en esa
mirada podremos encontrar probablemente
lo que no teníamos ni sospechar que
andábamos buscando un cuate una coche
una sede es un parche un pana un pata un
coche un compa un hombro un amigo
migrar
a veces es la única puerta de salida que
no sabemos cuánto tiempo va a permanecer
abierta y sin hacer mayor análisis
debemos cruzar
este es mi mano
no me deje sola soy inmigrante y estoy
aquí
[Aplausos]
[Música]